okay hi everyone welcome to cs330.
um if you're not here for cs330 you're
in the wrong place uh but hopefully
you're all in the right place
um we're going to start with some
introductions uh to get to know everyone
so I'm Chelsea I am an assistant
professor in the computer science and
electrical engineering departments at
Stanford uh and I'll be one of the
instructors of the course hi I'm Carl
um I will be also coming instructing the
curse together with Chelsea I'm an
Adjunct professor here at Stanford and
also research scientist at Google brain
we also have amazing Cas with us and we
can do a round of introductions for all
of them so let's start with Raphael
who's the heads here
you hear me so I'm right now I've been
working with Professor Finn for the last
year and a half two years
I mostly focused on things like offline
reinforcement learning method offline
memory personality
learning
sort of thing
questions I'm always available
but uh information
Ohio
hi everyone I'm a second year PhD I'm
advised by Chelsea and judge blue I
focus mostly on learning for Robotics
and welcome to the course
great
um so with that I think we can start the
first lecture uh welcome everyone it's
really amazing to see people in 3D in
person
um
of course we're still in the middle of a
pandemic and so uh
we understand that there might be
various challenges that come up in the
middle of the quarter and so forth
um
but it's uh really exciting to see
everyone here and we're going to try to
be understanding and so forth with
respect to different aspects of the
course for example the lectures are
being live streamed and also being
recorded and so if you have to miss a
lecture or can't be a lecture in person
we have everything available in that way
as well
um so first I want to just I don't know
hear how everyone is doing so uh do you
want to out of raise your hand and say
how you're doing
it could be one word answer something
longer yep pretty good
amazing morning
yeah
excellent okay
yeah multi-world lovely weather
it's pretty warm today
yeah excited
yeah excited to be back on campus
any anything on the zoom
okay cool okay lots of positive energy
this is great
cool
um so yeah um today we'll be talking
about Folsom course Logistics and then
also why study multitask learning and
meta learning
um so first let's start with some course
Logistics um this is kind of boring but
it's good to go through all of this um
also all the information is available on
the class website as well if you have
any questions or are not sure about
anything that I talk about
um so like I said this is the course
website uh all the information and
resources are available or linked on
there or through canvas uh we're going
to be using Ed for like q a and
discussion throughout the course uh and
this is connected to Canvas and you
should already be
um kind of automatically uh connected to
that if you're enrolled in the course
we also have a staff mailing list if you
have any questions that are uh kind of a
little bit more personal in nature and
not something that necessarily should go
on Ed or shouldn't be visible to
everyone or just to the core staff
um great and then we also have office
hours uh all the information on office
hours is on the uh the course website
and the office hours are going to start
on Wednesday
cool um so for the topics of this course
we're going to talk about
um a variety of things uh a lot of
things that are listed here multitask
learning meta learning the name of the
course including different kinds of meta
learning algorithms like block box
approaches optimization based approaches
and Metric learning approaches we'll get
some more advanced topics and also some
topics related to these kinds of
techniques in the context of
reinforcement learning and then we'll
also talk about things like lifelong
learning hierarchical RL and open
problems in the field
um there are a couple things that will
be new this quarter with respect to
previous quarters uh first we're going
to have a lecture on offline multitask
reinforcement learning which is a really
important uh and more up-and-coming
topic that I think is going to be
especially relevant in the coming years
and also a pretty exciting area
we're also going to have a guest lecture
on learning optimizers which is not a
topic that we've covered previously but
I think is pretty exciting as well and
an expert from Google will be coming and
talking about that
um of course there'll be an emphasis on
deep learning techniques uh there are a
lot of interesting techniques on some of
these topics outside of deep learning
but the focus of the course will be on
things related to deep learning
um then lastly throughout the course
either through the homeworks or through
the lectures we'll have some case
studies on various timely applications
this includes multitask learning and
recommender systems such as YouTube meta
learning for things like land cover
classification or in the context of
Education as well as things like few
shot learning and dpt3
um there's a couple topics that we won't
cover we won't cover topics like
architecture search or hyper parameter
optimization though a lot of the
underlying techniques that we'll talk
about will be kind of quite related to
these topics
okay um so
for lecture and office hours
um like I mentioned we have in-person
lecture we also have live stream Luxor
and recorded lecture uh the lecture is
being live streamed right now also for
those if people aren't able to make it
at the particular time everything will
be recorded and you'll have access to
the recordings through canvas after the
class this could also be useful if you
just want to kind of rewind to any part
of the course
um we're gonna have two guest lectures
uh one is by Colin Rafael who works on
transfer learning in natural language
processing he's a professor at UNC and
also spends some time at hugging face
and then we also will have a lecture
from Joshua Soul dickstein who works on
learning optimizers
uh during lecture I really encourage you
to ask questions I'm not here just to
talk uh I don't really like hearing
myself talk that much I love hearing all
of you talk and I'm yeah really here to
help you learn the material help you
um yeah explore and learn about new
topics and new areas and everything
becomes more interesting when you're
asking questions too
um if you have a question you can ask
the question by raising your hand you
could also enter your question into the
zoom chat or you can also raise your
hand in the zoom chat as well
um and then for office hours we're going
to have a mix of in-person and remote
office hours all of the instructor
office hours will be in person for the
first two weeks the TA office hours will
all be remote because of University room
scheduling challenges
um but after that some of them will also
be in person
and because it's often useful to have
different kinds of office hours we're
going to have a mix of pre-scheduled
office hours and drop-in office hours
that are managed with a queue this can
hopefully get the best of both worlds
where you can if you have some things
about like a project question for
example that you know well ahead of time
you can schedule it ahead of time but
also if you have something that's a
little bit more last minute or you want
the flexibility we'll also have drop-in
options as well
um
yeah
cool
um so also some of the prerequisites uh
cst29 is something equivalent to a
machine learning course is a
prerequisite
um and it's we also recommend some form
of previous or concurrent knowledge of
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is covered in
cst229 and cs221 and courses like that
and that sort of knowledge should be
sufficient and we'll try to fill in the
gaps for people who are less familiar
all the assignments will be based in
pytorch
and so if you aren't familiar with
pytorch we're going to be holding a
review session this will be over Zoom
pytorch seem to be what people preferred
in previous quarters and so that's a
change that we're making from from
previous years in which the the court
the assignments were in tensorflow
great and then we're also going to have
a couple other tutorial sessions one is
on variational inference this will be
useful for understanding one of the more
advanced lectures on Bayesian metal
learning
um and it's not required but if you're
interested in diving a little bit deeper
into the some of the topics in the
course this will be pretty relevant and
then we're also going to have a
reinforcement learning review tutorial
that will review some of the kinds of
basic reinforcement learning topics that
are covered in courses like cs229 and
cst21 if you have less reinforcement
learning background
great and these are both um either on a
Thursday or on a Tuesday and they're
going to be kind of more towards the
evening in general and the kind of more
information on the scheduling is
available on the website and so forth
great
um so assignments uh this is also
something that's gonna be a little bit
new this year we have a an optional
homework zero one of the feedbacks that
we had last year was that some students
wanted to get a flavor of the kinds of
things that they were going to be doing
in the course pretty early and get a
flavor for the way that we approach the
grading of the assignments um and so we
introduced this assignment that
discovers some of the basics of
multitask learning helps you check that
you have all of the kind of necessary
background knowledge for the course
um and uh and so forth I've never
sufficiently familiar with pytorch
we also have three homeworks that are uh
kind of graded and required
um that cover multitask learning meta
learning or different yeah multitask
learning about learning and multitask
reinforcement learning
uh and then one final optional homework
assignment on meta reinforcement
learning
um and we make this optional just
because it's towards the end of the
course and a project the project which
we'll talk about next is one of the big
parts of the course and we want to make
sure that you have enough time to work
on the project and and make progress on
that
um so the way that the grading will work
is that it's 45 homework and 55 project
um and so each of the kind of three
required homeworks will be 15 of your
grade
um the first homework will be uh worth
two percent of extra credit if you
decide to do it and the fourth homework
um will be kind of a full 15 and if you
choose to do it it will either replace
one of your homeworks or we'll replace
part of your project grade
um and we really designed this to
um to try to be give you some
flexibility uh and whatever we kind of
with regard to this last homework
assignment we're going to do whatever is
best for your grade and so for example
if you do it and it makes your grade
worse then we'll just not count it for
your grade
great and then um we also will provide
six total late days across all of the
assignments um including project related
assignments and a maximum of two late
days per assignment um and this just
helps us with grading things on time
okay um and then
lastly the final project is a big part
of the course um this is really a
research level project of your choice
that is related to the course material
uh you should do this in a group by
yourself or in a group of up to three
students
uh you're encouraged to use something
that's related to your research if it's
sufficiently kind of related to the
topic of the course and
I think that it's great if you can kind
of tie the two things together and often
leads to more interesting projects as
well
uh also
you can share the project with other
classes if you'd like although we often
um kind of will have a slightly higher
expectation in that case we're okay with
this if you also want to do this you
should check with the other course as
well based on their policies
um and then lastly it's the same late
day policies as homeworks there's no
late days for the poster or the final
report um and this is so that uh we can
grade things on time before the the
University grading deadline
great and then we're also going to have
a poster uh session the time and
location are still TBD we're still
working on reserving a venue for that
cool
um so those are most of the logistics
are there any questions about the
logistics I know I've been through a lot
yeah
yeah
students who aren't taking the course
part of the project will involve a
collaboration statement and so you
should kind of write out the
contributions of everyone including
people who aren't taking the course
yeah
sorry what okay yeah so you can either
do it by yourself or in a group of up to
three students
any questions on Zoom
okay great well if you any more
questions come up feel free to put them
in Ed
um or or ask one of us in office hours
or something like that
um as kind of initial steps in in terms
of getting started with the course um
the first kind of optional homework zero
is uh is posted or if it's not posted
it'll be posted like within the next
couple hours and so if you want to get
started on that you can
um and also I encourage you to start
forming project groups if you want to
work on a group and start thinking about
what you want to do for your project
okay yeah
oh great so
um
you're welcome to discuss the homeworks
with other people but we ask that you
write up your solution independently uh
and if including any sort of code and so
forth we also have more details on our
honor code policy on the website and
you're encouraged to take a look at that
um
yeah
great
um so now I want to talk a little bit
about uh kind of why I think this course
topic is really exciting
um and I think that's exciting for a
number of different reasons and I'm
going to start by talking about some of
my research and why I'm personally
excited about a lot of these topics
um Carl will then talk about why he's
excited about the topic and then we'll
also kind of zoom out and provide a kind
of broader perspective on why these
topics are important And Timely
great so one of the questions that I'm
really interested in in my research is
how we can allow agents to learn a
breadth of skills in the real world
and by agents I mean actual physical
robots in the world so here are some
videos of kind of some of the things
that we've had robots do in my research
lab uh in this case actually this is I'm
holding the block here the robot learned
how to place the Sorting Cube into the
corresponding hole
we've also looked at scenarios where we
want to have the robot be able to watch
a video of a human do something and have
the robot figure out how to solve the
task
and also see if robots can figure out
how to use tools in order to accomplish
tasks as well
and I'm really fascinated by problems
like this because uh robots I think can
teach us things about intelligence
uh this might sound a little bit uh
funny because robots aren't intelligent
uh themselves but robots are faced with
the real world they have to be able to
generalize across different tasks and
across different environments in order
to be useful
they need some sort of Common Sense
understanding in order to perform well
and uh
also supervision can't really be taken
for granted you have a robot like in a
physical space and it's not even really
clear what the supervision should be um
you don't have like you're not given
just a label data set for example
um and I think that all these sorts of
things make it a really fascinating
problem because a lot of these are like
the things that humans are faced with
when they're trying to learn and become
more intelligent
um and so we'll first start by kind of
telling a little bit of story from here
which is that at the beginning of my PhD
um there was a project that was trying
to see how robots can learn
and
I was kind of sitting in kind of an area
right next to this robot I was watching
it learned like this in this case is
trying to learn how to assemble the toy
plan essentially is trying to learn how
to place the wheels into the into the
toy plane
and I think it's really fascinating
because the robot is actually learning
through trial and error how to solve the
task at the very beginning it knew
nothing about how to solve the task and
by the end it actually becomes quite
proficient at solving the task
um that said there was a bit of a catch
which is that uh the robots had its eyes
closed the whole entire time and it was
just doing this purely based on feel
essentially
and from there
um a kind of Pretty Natural next step is
well can it actually also learn how to
see as well as learn how to actually
move its arms as well
um and so that's what what uh one of the
first products I did during my PhD was
trying to see can we have the robot
learn through trial and error both
learning a perception system essentially
learning a neural network that takes his
input images from the robot's camera and
outputs torque supplied to the robot's
joints in order to solve the task
um and you can see at the beginning the
robot was kind of just moving his arm
around randomly and over time it's
learning not just how to move its arm
but also how to kind of figure out where
the the box is so that it can put the uh
the block into the corresponding hole
um and so
you can see the um kind of the final
policy here where I'm kind of holding
the block out for the robot and the the
robot's point of view is on the bottom
right
and what was pretty exciting about this
algorithm wasn't that the robot learned
this one skill but that the robot could
learn lots of different skills so you
can use the same sort the same exact
algorithm to learn something like
putting the the claw of a toy hammer
underneath the nail
uh and like screwing a cap onto a bottle
for example
um and also use a very similar algorithm
to use a spatula to lift an object into
a bowl
um so this means it may seem like a
little bit of a tangent
um overall we were really excited about
this sort of approach
but there was a kind of a pretty huge
catch with all of this
which is that uh the robot in this case
uh what I learned wasn't how to use
spatulas to lift objects into bowls it
had learned how to use that spatula to
lift that object into that bowl
and if you give the robot a different
spatula or ask it to do something else
or gave it a different bowl or change
the environment
the robot wouldn't be able to solve the
task
and this is a problem because ultimately
we want robots to be able to do lots of
different tasks not just one very narrow
skill
and so in many ways this is the
motivation in my mind behind trying to
build systems that are more General and
that can do many different tasks
so around the same time people also use
the same algorithm to do other skills
like hitting a puck into a goal like
opening a door like throwing an object
to hit a Target and around the same time
people are also developing approaches
for playing games like Atari or go or
learning how to walk
but in all of these cases they were
learning one task in one environment
starting from scratch
now you might say okay I know how to
solve this problem we just need to give
the robot more spatulas and then it'll
learn how to do the test with many
spatulas and we need to give it more
tasks and I'll learn that and so forth
but there's also a catch with that
which is that if you look behind the
scenes in a lot of these learning
processes in many cases it looks
something like this
where the robot tries the task
and then the environment needs to kind
of be reset to some initial State and
then the robot tries the task again
and so forth
and one of the things you might notice
here this is my friend yevgen and devgan
is doing more work than the robot is
doing
and this is kind of silly like we want
robots to be able to kind of learn by
themselves autonomously and in this way
it's actually yavkin is like doing a lot
of the the work to do this learning
process rather than the robot
um it's not practical to collect a lot
of data across a lot of different tasks
in this way and so we need new
techniques in order to allow robots and
other systems to learn many different
tasks rather than just one task
um so I talked about this a lot in the
context of Robotics but this isn't just
a problem in robotics and reinforcement
learning uh if we look at a lot of the
kind of state-of-the-art machine
Learning Systems a lot of them are
specialized for one individual task like
translating between one language pair or
recognizing speech or detecting certain
objects
so these are often in more diverse
settings but there's still one task
starting from scratch uh with pretty
detailed supervision and I'll refer to
all these systems as sort of specialists
in the sense that they're solving just a
single task
and ultimately we want uh systems maybe
to be a little bit more like humans that
can they're more like generalists that
can do lots of different things and
learn in richer worlds than the kinds of
robots that I was showing before
and then one last note on this in terms
of my motivation is that I think that if
you look at a system like alphago and a
lot of the reinforcement learning
systems that I showed before they're
somewhat analogous to essentially
teaching a baby on day one to play Go
uh and from that standpoint it's
actually really silly to train systems
specialize for a single task uh it's
kind of ridiculous to think that you can
learn a single task really well without
learning about other aspects of the
world and so
and so okay um and with that uh Carl
will come and talk about uh a little bit
more about why he cares about multitask
learning and Better Learning
okay Chelsea
all right so um in my PhD I was also
working on robots and I was working on
initially I was working more on
classical robotic pipelines where we
have a perception system that has to
perceive the world and then the robot
has to look at the output of that
perception system and do something in
that world
and when I was working on it I realized
that it's actually really really hard so
if perception system fails at some point
and it fails in a way that the the robot
doesn't really know what to do with it
the whole system breaks apart
and um at that point during during my
PhD I attended the talk by Sergey Levin
who is now a professor at Berkeley who
started talking about similar things
that Chelsea just talked about about
robots that learned through deep neural
networks that learn end to end a whole
bunch of different tasks and that
interact with the environment and
optimize the entire Pipeline and learn
how to have to do things
and I got really inspired by that so I
changed the topic of my PhD and I
started working on on the Deep
reinforcement learning instead
um and right now what really excites me
is that I really want to see how the
recipe that has worked in in other
fields such as computer vision or
language the the recipe where we apply
modern machine learning methods to a
field and it is able to do really really
well in that field how can we apply a
similar recipe to robotics
so if we look at that recipe it consists
of two things so first we need a lot of
data
for instance the size of the imagenet
the million images so that we can we
have enough data to optimize our neural
net
or in natural language processing maybe
we need all of Wikipedia
anyway we need a lot of data
and then we need expressive capable
models that will be able to digest all
of this data so in computer vision
traditionally these have been
convolutional neural Nets and in
language processing these have been
mostly Transformers now being applied
also to to computer vision and to many
other domains
so if we just were to look at this and
see what would it take to apply the same
recipe for robotics
in terms of expressive capable
expressive capable models it's actually
fairly easy right we we use very similar
libraries we can look at pytorch or
tensorflow or anything else take the
best model that was applied to let's say
natural language processing and just
apply it to robots
but when it comes to data it's a little
more tricky we we can just go on the
internet and download a scrape off a
whole bunch of robotic data that is high
quality where robots do a lot of things
but actually I think it's a little bit
more nuanced than that
and with a lot of data if we look at
some of the results in reinforcement
learning for instance we actually do
have a lot of data so here is one
example of a work from open AI over
robot learning how to operate this uh
this uh this little Cube here and
actually the the amount of experience
that they had to collect in simulation
was equivalent to a hundred years
and we see in many reinforcement
learning robotic reinforcement learning
experiments that we actually do have a
lot of data for these tasks
however if we were to double the size of
that data of the data set we would see
that at some point the performance
starts to plateau and we don't really
see much benefit in providing more data
to the robot the robot already mastered
the task or learned as much as it could
from that data set extracted all the
information and even if we were to pour
much much more data the robot is not
really going to improve it's not going
to learn more about the world
however if we look at supervised
learning at the data sets such as
imagenet if we were to double the size
of that of that data set I would bet
that the the the algorithm would
actually get better
and the reason for this is that imagenet
is much more diverse image that has many
different categories not just one
category it has images of things in the
real world with different backgrounds
from different angles taken by different
people and so on
and I believe that's what we need for
robots as well
we need to have data sets that uh that
are multitask data sets that consist of
multiple robots in many different
environments doing different things
so here I should be a little bit more
precise and say that we don't just need
a lot of data but we need a lot of
diverse multitask data
and in this course we'll talk about what
are the challenges associated with that
but also once we have that data how can
we utilize it best to learn multitask
policies that can so that robots can
learn how to do many different things
and how they can discover structure
between these tasks so that learning
each task is more efficient
and this is why I'm really excited about
multitask RL and meta Rail and all these
things
so this is the reason that I usually
give people why I work on these things
but there's actually uh the real reason
that I want to reveal to you right now
so you remember this little video that
Chelsea just showed of you have again
resetting the puck
and uh helping Robert to learn how to
how to play hockey
so there's actually one more person in
this room
and this is the room this is the robot
learning how to play hockey
and
this is me a few years ago with a little
ponytail that I'm not very proud of
resetting the puck
and uh this damn Park I spent so much
time with it and this was probably one
of the lowlights of my PhD spending the
entire night resetting the [ __ ]
and I don't wish any PhD student to ever
have to do this again so please let's
work on multitasker enforcement learning
so we can automate these things
all right I'll move it over to Chelsea
great so uh that was kind of the present
the perspect from Robotics and a lot of
the research that that I do and that
Carl does but
um Beyond Robotics and Beyond trying to
build more general purpose machine
Learning Systems um there's also a lot
of other reasons to consider and think
about these kinds of topics
um so first uh why should we care in
particular about deep multitask and
metal learning
um like Carl alluded to before deep
learning there were these more kind of
hand designed pipelines for building AI
systems
and so for example a system like this
use something like these hog features
that are hand designed to try to pick
out different kinds of features in an
image and then you would do some sort of
deforable part model on top of that
feature which is another hand design
tool and then maybe you do a tiny bit of
learning on top of that with an svm
and with modern computer vision this
kind of changed the way that people
approach the problem and instead of
trying to hand design different aspects
of a pipeline they instead would just
learn everything in this end-to-end
fashion from data
and the reason why this recipe or this
this kind of second approach is really
exciting is that it allows us to be able
to handle unstructured inputs it means
that we can handle things like pixels
language sensor readings directly rather
than having to deal with
um rather than having to assume that we
have access to some of our structured
features that are extracted from these
more unstructured inputs
um and this means that we don't need
hand engineer features we don't need as
much domain knowledge as well and as a
result these approaches are actually
often much more applicable than
approaches that require a very detailed
domain knowledge
um and Beyond not requiring uh domain
knowledge they also work really well so
if you look at image that performance
over multiple different years uh
you see there's a little bit of a phase
transition between uh
kind of right here basically in 2012.
and that was Alex net and this was
essentially really the first deep neural
network that was successful end up being
applied to the imagenet data set and uh
really led to this whole phase
transition and led to much better
performance and afterwards everything
after here is is neural networks
um it's not just true in computer vision
also in machine translation
um uh this paper by Google showed that
you can apply deep neural networks to
machine translation and if you look at
the kind of the performance differences
between a kind of a phrase-based system
which is
um kind of a more hand-designed system
versus their neural machine translation
system you also see a pretty huge jump
in performance and this is actually you
also see a big jump in performance and
tools like Google translate because of
the use of neural networks
okay so that's why deep learning
um yeah
great so the question was are images and
text structured data um and those are
examples of things I would consider
unstructured data because they are
um they're just kind of the things that
the really the kinds of data that you
would see that's very raw that's uh
directly recorded from a sensor or
directly recorded from the internet
forms of structured data would be more
things like higher level features that
are like for example whether there's a
cat in the image or not or kind of what
the high level shape of an image is or
certain topics of an article for example
okay so that's motivating deep learning
um hopefully there isn't too much more
motivation needed for deep learning
um now why deep multitask learning and
metal learning
so there's several reasons for this
um
the first is that we've seen kind of
this recipe of taking deep learning and
applying it to large and diverse data
sets and getting broad generalization
and we've seen this with imagenet we've
seen it with Transformers we've seen it
with Google Translate
but what if you don't have a large data
set
there's a whole host of settings and
applications where you don't have access
to a huge data set right off the bat
this could be in medical imaging and
Robotics in translation from more rare
languages and personalized education in
medicine and recommender systems and so
forth
and there's all of these applications
that often the machine learning
community may not be studying quite as
much because they don't have these huge
data sets and we want to be able to
apply and leverage the success of deep
learning in settings like this as well
and
for example it's impractical to try to
learn from scratch for every single
disease or every single robot or every
person or every language essentially
it's impractical to learn from scratch
for every single task
and if you can instead pool data and
information across tasks and from
previous tasks then this will allow us
to actually apply deep learning and
leverage the success of deep learning in
these kinds of domains
so this is one example
um another example maybe you have a
large data set but your data set has a
long tail
where some parts of the data set you
have a lot of examples and a lot of it's
very well represented and other parts of
the data set is not well represented you
have only a small number of examples
so for example if you look at the
distribution of objects that a system
has encountered for some objects that
may have encountered them a lot whereas
other objects that may have only
encountered them once or a few times
um and this might be true for a lot of
different things maybe some people
you've interacted with a lot and some
people you've interacted with only a
little or it could be the words that
you've heard or different driving
scenarios and so on and so forth
I mean further distributions actually
pop up all the time in real world
problems
that essentially follow this sort of
power law
and the setting also breaks the standard
machine learning Paradigm where you kind
of assume that you have a nicer
distribution and that your training test
distribution match
okay um so those are two reasons
um as a third reason what if you learn
need to learn something new quickly
maybe you need to learn something about
a new person about a new task about a
new environment and so forth
um to give an example of this I'd like
to give all of you a little test
and in particular I'm going to give you
a training data set which are these six
images on the left
and your goal is to be able to solve a
classification problem using this
training data set
and in particular the three images on
the far left are paintings that were
painted by Brooke and the three
paintings in the second column are
painting spices on
and your goal is to try to look at these
and learn from the six data points and
ultimately be able to classify the data
point on the right
and so after giving you a second to look
at this
[Music]
um
how many of you think that this is a
painting by Cezanne raise your hand
and how many of you think that this is a
painting by Brock
cool
it's a little bit close but I think the
majority was for Brock
and that would be the correct answer and
you can if you learn from this carefully
you can see that there's actually a lot
of these kind of sharp Contours in the
painting and you can use that that sort
of feature to recognize the style of
Brock I made this a little bit harder on
purpose if you look more at the colors
actually I think that you might I guess
stays on
um but yeah once you look at it a little
bit more closely you can figure out that
it's wrong
cool so
this is an example where if you just
gave a neural network and you trained it
from scratch on six examples
it would have no chance of being able to
complete this task
and so this is what's called flu shot
learning
and the way that you accomplish this is
that you may not have seen these
paintings before or maybe even painters
paintings from these painters
but you do have previous experience
um you have previous experience maybe
looking at different kinds of paintings
you got your visual system is pretty
good it has previous experience as well
and you can leverage that previous
experience along with the small data set
in order to learn very quickly from just
a few examples
okay
um so overall uh some of the reasons
Beyond building more general purpose
systems and allowing robots to be
generalists for caring about multitask
learning and meta learning include
trying to solve scenarios where you
don't have a large data set where your
data has a long tail or where you want
to quickly learn something new
um so essentially these are all elements
where there are all scenarios where
elements of multitask learning and metal
learning can come into play
okay
um now I want to try to dive into a
little bit more of kind of what do I
actually mean by multitask learning and
so forth and what actually is a task
we'll Define what a task is more
formally on Wednesday but for now you
can think of a task as something that it
has a data set and a loss function and
your goal is to learn a model that
minimizes the loss function on that data
set
and then different tasks can vary in
different ways
maybe the data set has different objects
in it for example uh or maybe different
people in it different objective
functions so maybe the data set is the
same but you have different loss
functions on it that would be called
multi-objective optimization
maybe it corresponds to different
lighting conditions or different words
different languages and so forth
and the purpose of giving these examples
is that
[Music]
um
multitask learning can refer to things
that aren't just different tasks in the
English sense of the word task
it can essentially correspond to things
that would correspond more to like
different domains or different different
objectives and so forth they're
essentially just different machine
learning problems and you want to
combine those machine learning problems
in a way that allows you to learn better
there is one critical assumption to
basically everything in the course
which is that the tasks need to share
some form of structure
um this is kind of the bad news and if
they don't share any structure at all
then you're just better off using single
task learning because you're not going
to be able to actually benefit from
using data from other tasks
the good news though is that there are
many tasks with shared structure
um so for example if you want to learn
how to kind of open a jar versus unscrew
a bottle versus kind of uh grind some
pepper for example all of these have
kind of a shared structure similar
motions for example
and even if the tasks are seemingly
somewhat unrelated a lot of data has
shared structure by nature of the fact
that the laws of physics underlie a lot
of real data or for example people are
all organisms with intentions or the
rules of English will underlie all
English language data
um or even if you're learning across
different languages they might share
similar purposes
and so as a result of this uh this can
lead to a lot more structure than purely
random tasks
and uh and it makes things like
multitask learning and better learning
more general purpose and more applicable
so I guess the question was that the it
seems like humans have a single model
that learns everything and is it proven
that they need to that there needs to be
some shared structure
um I guess what I'll say is that uh
if they don't share any structure if
they're completely independent then you
still can use multitask learning it just
means that it won't do any better
necessarily than learning them
independently
um and so you still can use it and in
some ways it might be fine to to use it
uh
there are kind of practical challenges
so if you learn things that are
completely independent then you might
need more capacity or the network might
kind of harder optimization problem but
in principle you should be able to do
just as well as training a single model
also try to give um I'll go I'll give a
more formal definition of what I mean by
structure in some of the coming lectures
especially when we talk about Bayesian
models which gives us actually a very
nice language for talking about
structure with respect to like
Independence assumptions for example
so the question is can different tasks
have different data sets or do you have
to share the same data set
um it can be either you can share the
entire data set and just have different
labels for example
um you could have completely different
data sets as well
great so the question is how do you
verify if two tasks share the same
structure uh this is actually
challenging and this is um in some ways
a kind of an open research question in
some ways uh
if we have time tomorrow I'll try to
talk a little bit about sorry on
Wednesday I'll try to talk about that
question a little bit on Wednesday if we
have time
that's a great question it actually can
be quite Dynamic and it can actually go
in both directions so as an intuitive
example say you want to kind of pick up
a water bottle and pour or maybe you
want to pick up a clicker and click or
something if you don't know how to grasp
objects yet then they probably share a
lot of structure because learning to
grasp both of them is quite related but
once you learn how to grasp objects they
might actually start appearing very
different because the task of clicking
versus pouring are probably very
different from one another and so
how much structure is shared may also
depend on what the model knows as well
in the back
is there an analogous requirement for
multimodal data so do you mean multiple
data modalities
yeah so
um
yeah in general you could also you can
also apply these techniques to
multimodal data for example maybe you
have RGB images and depth images for
example and you want to learn from both
of those you do still need there to be
some shared structure uh to learn from
that
um
also you could also do single test
learning in a multimodal setting by
combining the modalities and I wouldn't
necessarily consider that as multitask
learning
um but there may be ways to formulate it
that are related
so you're asking does the benefits of
multitask learning come
foreign
so
yeah I think that both are important I
think that both the common structure is
important as well as the neural
Network's ability to generalize
um I think that the fact that neural
networks can usually uh generalize very
well within their data distribution is
is quite helpful if they end up
memorizing the data then
um
then leveraging multiple tasks I think
becomes more challenging
first
no they don't the question was do they
need to share the same output space and
they don't um you can essentially have
an architecture that kind of essentially
even splits into two outputs foreign
yeah so the definition of a task is
somewhat fluid uh and you could imagine
scenarios where
um
where you even have hierarchies of tasks
potentially as well and there isn't
necessarily like one ground truth
definition of what a task should be it
could be something as low level as like
um I don't know grasping a tool it could
also be something at higher level like
fixing a bike for example
um and it is something that is uh yeah
it's it is rather
um there's no like single definition
um and that's why I like to think of it
as something that takes his input a data
set and a loss function and produces a
model
um because this this really puts it in
more kind of concrete terms and allows
the um the practitioner to Define it
appropriately
great so
um
I also like to just briefly talk about
some informal problem definitions and
again we'll formalize this next on on
Wednesday
um so what what I mean by multitask
learning uh in general what I mean by
this is trying to learn a set of tasks
more quickly than trying to learn them
independently from one another
or more proficiently than learning them
independently um so basically you're
given a set of tests and you want to
solve that set of tasks
and then the middle earring problem is a
little bit different in the middle
learning problem or at least the one
that we're going to use in this class
you're given data on a set of previous
tasks and your goal is to learn a knee
task more quickly or more proficiently
um and this is an important distinction
because in the multitask learning
problem you aren't necessarily trying to
be able to kind of adapt or learn
something new you're just trying to
learn what you are given whereas in meta
learning you want to be able to actually
adapt to a new task and this often means
that you use a different kind of
approach for solving this problem
and also say that these are the kind of
the problem statements and these are
kind of different from the actual
methods that you use to solve them
and then essentially in this course
we'll talk about anything that solves
these problem statements
yeah
yeah
great so in transfer learning
um I was thinking about putting this on
the slide but I decided not to
um so in transfer learning it actually
the transfer learning problem is very
similar to the med learning problem
sometimes also in the transfer learning
problem you're only given a single
Source task rather than a set of source
tasks but in many ways the problem is
basically the same as the meta learning
problem the techniques are the methods
end up being quite different in meta
learning you explicitly optimize for the
ability to learn new tasks whereas in
transfer learning the kinds of
approaches often try to design things
that will transfer well to new tasks but
they aren't optimizing for the ability
to transfer
given us
yeah so the question is will a multitask
system always perform better than a
single task system given the same data
um and
the answer is no um so sometimes
multitask systems might run into
optimization challenges
um and that caused them to actually
perform worse than the single test
system trained even trained
independently on things but in principle
you should be able to get to at least
this little level performance as a
single test system and we'll get into
the specifics of that in some ways on
Wednesday
okay now you might be wondering well in
the multitask learning scenario where we
want to learn a set of tasks
can't we just reduce this to single toss
learning and in particular
what we could do is just take the union
of all the data sets and take the sum of
all the loss functions and now you have
a single data set and a single loss
function and you have a single task
learning problem
so maybe we're done with the course
um
and in some ways it can actually reduce
to single test learning which is great
you can just aggregate the data set and
learn a single model and this is a very
reasonable approach to multitask
learning
uh but we can often do better than this
and there are often techniques that we
can use to either exploit the fact that
we know that the data is coming from
different tasks and leverage that
assumption to do better or in the meta
learning scenario we can actually
leverage the assumption that we know
that we want to learn something new and
um and try to actually optimize for the
ability to learn something new
um so what we'll be talking about in the
course is how we can actually exploit
that fact and how we can do better than
just reducing it to a single test
problem
okay
um and then the last thing we'll talk
about is why we should cover multitask
learning and meta learning why we should
study that now
and the reason why I think this is
important is if you look at some papers
from the 90s for example
um
they kind of they actually talk a lot
about multitask learning and so forth um
so they talk about how you want to
potentially
run training tasks in parallel while
using some sort of shared representation
uh you want to leverage multitask
inductive structure
you want to be able to generalize
correctly even from a single training
example so this one shot learning
problem or the the possibility for a
learning rule to learn how to solve new
tasks
so a lot of these ideas actually existed
um in the 90s maybe before some of you
were born in some cases uh
that said uh these algorithms are really
continuing to play a fundamental role in
machine learning research and machine
learning applications
uh so as some examples uh people have
been applying these kinds of techniques
to learn machine translation for lots of
different languages rather than just a
single language trying to simultaneously
learn how to translate 100 languages and
you can surpass kind of strong bilingual
baselines
uh Colin Rafael who is one of our guest
speakers author often authored this text
to text Transformer paper that solves
lots of different tasks within a single
model and this is a model that's I think
been quite popular uh today and and so
forth
um we've seen examples in robotics so
the ability to learn from a video of a
human to be able to solve a task
in just one shot
I mean in many ways a lot of these
advances are actually powered by the
fact that deep learning has been uh more
successful these days with the power of
gpus and with with larger data sets and
more computational power
um as another example in robotics is the
ability to kind of learn across multiple
different domains by training in lots of
different environments to get a system
that can actually generalize to the real
world by training on all of those
environments
and then as one last example a paper
that we'll actually cover on Wednesday
is multitask learning in YouTube
recommendation systems that try to
actually optimize multiple competing
objectives for ranking the videos
okay um in these algorithms I think are
also just playing not just an important
role in research and so forth right now
but they're also playing an increasing
role in machine learning research
um it's a little bit difficult to
measure uh the role that they're playing
in research but we can look at measures
like search queries and citations and we
see a trend that is uh that is going
upward and people are getting more
excited and interested in these
approaches
um also if you look at kind of citations
of papers that are related to transfer
learning meta learning and multitask
learning we also see increasing interest
as well
um and then lastly I think that the
success of these kinds of algorithms
will be really important if we care
about making deep learning accessible to
lots of different applications and lots
of different people
so if you look at a lot of the data sets
that are used in the machine Learning
Community things like imagenet WMT
switchboard and so forth and all these
have really massive data sets they have
1.2 million images or 20 or 40.8 million
sentences or 300 hours of labeled data
and if you contrast this to other
problems that we also care deeply about
like diabetic retinopathy detection this
dataset has 35 000 labeled images which
is drastically smaller than the data
sets uh before
or if we want to look at epilepsy
treatment this paper used less than one
hour of data or in kind of an example
from a robotics paper we use less than
15 minutes of data
and if we want to be able to learn from
small amounts of data we should try to
leverage other data sets and larger data
sets and learn how to learn how to
leverage those data sets in a way that
allows us to transfer and solve these
other kinds of small problems with small
amounts of data
possibility
yeah so the question is can you perform
multitask learning and meta learning on
the same network
um often in often cases metal learning
algorithms will actually also learn how
to solve the training tasks and so in
that sense uh yes you can
okay um and then the last thing that
I'll mention is that uh this is a field
that is like like I mentioned is this
growing in interest and so forth and so
we also still have a lot of open
questions and open challenges and in
many ways I think that this is what
makes the field so exciting there's lots
of really new problems to solve and uh
and so there'll be scenarios potentially
in this course where maybe you'll ask a
question and it's kind of an open
problem in the field and uh maybe that
means that it's a project that you
should investigate in your project for
example
um or or something that um yeah that
we'll see we'll see in future work
applied
great
um so that's it for the main content of
today it'll be a bit of a shorter
lecture I think than um than future
lectures which will take up the full uh
80 minutes
as a couple reminders the first optional
homework is out um and also encourage
you to start forming project groups
um and I'll also happy to take any
remaining questions if there are them or
you can come up to the front as well